welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and while Loki season 2 introduces
several new characters with dubious
intentions a few characters from season
1 are mysteriously missing still any of
our Kang variants like Victor timley
Rona Rin Slayer but specifically Miss
minutes she's on no screen time in this
Premiere episode as we look ahead to
next week's episode we are diving into
the mystery of Miss minute's
disappearance and all of our other
questions we have about the rest of
season 2 this is a new format we're
calling the sneak peek where we take the
temperature of whatever we're watching
while we head into the next episode or
look ahead to the next week and nerdom
joining me on this Quest my inside
Marvel OG Jessica
Clemens hi I love Miss minutes I I do
too I do I love her maybe a little bit
too much I think everybody
does where is she I mean look she's
shown up in like little um visuals here
and there uh a a bumper sticker um you
know just smiling at us from every
poster but I miss her voice I know it's
I look here we're going to get it
eventually I'm sure I'm sure or we're
just going to get me doing the character
bit of her all the time I can't do a Mis
minutes impression which is the easiest
impression to do in all of the world and
I still cannot do it to this day anytime
I say hey y'all I go hey y'all oh God
that's just my normal that's okay I
think that was a pretty good I don't
think you can do a bad Mis minutes
impression you wonder why cuz she's oh
talking hologram and she's nothing
aren't we all and everything all right
aren't we all just part of a simulation
God what a weird show this is but I'm
loving it and I'm so happy to be here
talking about it with you guys I'm so
excited uh there there's been too many
questions I've had already from this
first episode but I think that's what
makes a great pilot episode not even
pilot a Premiere episode because this is
our second season so it feels like a
pilot it do it okay I'm not the only one
feeling it then okay good cuz it does
feel like a pilot episod episode it
feels like they dropped this and was
like oh we're in New Territory let's get
into it and leaving off that Cliff anger
of like who pruned Loki or who was on
the other end of that phone call that
was just buzzing the entire time I
thought it was a horror scene I it did
feel scary there's a million things
happening there's a million questions
but I think the number one question is
where the hell is Miss minutes
especially after all of what she did in
the last season yeah and and I I love
this question because it's a question we
could ask at all time for all time
always where is Miss minutes where is
her source code because like anytime
we're seeing her she just kind of like
floats around through space she's a
ghost and we know it's some future
episode this season based off of the
trailer footage she's going to take on I
think that's even like an intentional
meta wink that like all right I'm just
gonna be a ghost because that's
essentially what I am yeah but like they
they know how much we love her because
they added her to the Marvel Studios
title card opening like that was the one
new thing cuz he remains had been there
before he was there in quantam mania
this time they added her to the opening
yeah um so I think right now she is like
standing over the corpse of he who
remains in the Citadel that's where I
think like where she is at any conscious
she's kind of like Heisenberg
uncertainty principle right I think she
could be anytime you measure her she
disappears so do we know where she went
from in the last season the last she was
talking to Sylvia and Loki and then she
just kind of left and then he who
remained showed up and we have not seen
or heard of her since right that the
last time
last time we saw her she yeah you're
right she scared the out of all of
us in the Citadel entrance room and then
yeah she talked to Riner for a little
bit like didn't she bring the paperwork
back to Riner and she goes actually
sorry that's classified which just kind
of shows that like there's stuff that he
miss minutes knew that Riner didn't know
okay oh my and now she's offline yeah
was Loki was trying to or not Loki um
Mobius was trying to reach her and was
like I can't reach her but do you think
it's intentional that she's offline do
you think she's just hiding inside of a
computer I think well I think by Offline
that tells us that she's probably synced
in some way to he who remains
Consciousness oh okay so when he was
stabbed by Sylvie I imagine he's kind of
like a wack-a-mole he's going to he's
going to reboot in some other form and I
think she is now attached to like
whatever like you know she's like kind
of his fa I think he data dumps his
memories into her and then she has like
instructions now of like what do next
like she might have his will in
Testament and it's kind of like
reporting that to like some other you
know to like whoever the next in line in
succession is if it's like phro Tut or
Scarlet Centurion that's insane to use
her like a flash drive to just use her
as a flash drive oh could we see you
know in knives out when like Jim Le
Curtis is sitting there and they're all
reading the will and testament of the
patriarch of the family can we have a
scene with all the different Kang
variants from the quantum media mid
credit scene just like in that scene of
knives out and there's like one of them
who's just like oh I thought I inherited
the Spinx and then one is just Chris
Evans wearing that same knit sweater
from knives out I'll kill him I'll kill
him I'll kill him if he shows back up in
the MCU as a Kang barant in a in a
Christmas sweater that is insane to
think of Miss I like I want to think so
much highly of her than like being like
the the not the trauma dump the the like
knowledge dump to the Kings only because
all of the press that's outside of this
she is still the face like we went to
the um we went to the whatever uh and we
saw that like they put her face on the
coffee mugs they put her face everywhere
and I was like there she has to be super
big to everything if they're going to
just put her on everything and she's not
even in the first episode so I want to
believe that she's more than just like
the flash drive to the king I want I
want to believe that and especially with
um what did he say uh Obie was like yeah
she does all of the overseeing I just
check on it every few 100 years I was
like oh is she ahead of he who remains
is there something that she's been
running on him that he doesn't know yet
oh yeah I mean when I call her the flash
drive of he remains that's not like an
insult I think that's like a very
important status because I bet there are
memories that he has that are too
painful for him that he gives to her
like she knows all of his secrets and so
in some ways she's more powerful than
even he is because he's just like the
steeve jobs to I was about to say to was
but I think
I think Miss is like Kate Winslet's um
assistant character from the 2015 Steve
Jobs mie who was a real person who was
like his long the one person to stay
with him despite no matter how many
times he was like pruned out of Apple's
existence yeah this you know his
longtime executive assistant who really
was like in some ways the method to his
Madness is there um is there still a
world I don't know if people still
believe this Theory maybe it's just that
it got on me that Miss minutes is a
variant of ravona Ren Slayer and she
just has all that information and has
been I think I would love that reveal
that yeah I would love that reveal and
also the reveal that like you thought
Kang was the bad one you thought it was
all Kang but it actually was just raona
this entire time like she's like the
Puppeteer she's the master um and then
this minutes by proxy uh but we think
she's just offline just offline I think
she's offline in the same way that like
Kang or he remains is currently offline
he's being rebooted and maybe just like
the one that they had access to in the
in the present of the TVA was the one
that was like that version of he who
remains who is killed off so it's just
currently offline but I think somewhere
there is a a rebooted version of Miss
minutes who has respawned somewhere
that's a ghost yeah GH it could have
just been like she wakes up in in the
World's Fair or something like that do
you think she would have her memorate
also when you say rebooting he who
remains you think he's just like slight
lightly dead in the Citadel and then
he's I think his corpse is going to stay
there but like you know how when you
kill an Ultron Century the shell the
robot's shell stays there but Ultron
wakes up somewhere else I think that's
kind of like what we know Kang to be his
Consciousness is just detached in
general it's floating around it's like
Lucy it's like Scarlet it's like
Johnny Depp in that movie Transcendent
where I didn't see that movie no one saw
that movie see that movie why you like
also you came in like yeah like people
have seen that movie I know what movie
you're talking about I don't think I
Dash have you seen that freaking movie
that's has even seen that movie no
that's the only movie Dash watches cuz
he uh
trans what why would you quote that
movie I'm sorry I don't know why that
made me so mad I think it's just that
you made it seem like people have seen
that movie I don't think would see that
movie Johnny de has made so many movies
that so many people have seen but not
Transcendent um all right we should we
should move on I feel like we covered
some interesting ground of where Mis
minutes can be um But be sure to check
out nerd rot. shop where you can always
grab the latest and greatest in new
rockstars gear right now you can check
out our new line of merch inspired by
the new season of Loki including our
special breakroom Le G shirt uh support
the channel and check out our great
merch options over at nerd rot. shop and
don't forget to subscribe to all three
channels of the new rockstars Network
new rock stars the break room in the
Deep dive um by the way L speaking of a
moonight was I might have missed this in
our breakdown the um the guided
meditation that Casey is listening to
might have been the same guided
meditation that um that stepen Grant was
listening damn it it might have been go
look it go listen to it watch I made not
it I made a note of it and then I was
like this is just weird I just thought
like of course Casey's listening to this
but that' be very insane if it's the
same thing now long time new rockstars
viewers know how much we use geology and
how long we've been using it for but if
this is your first time hearing about
geology get ready for Block Blockbuster
quality Skin Care on a student film
budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
G's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one of the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to g l og. i/
rockstars 100 to get started okay so we
heard a recording of he remains and
raona talking to each other
which so much stuff is happening in this
first episode uhhuh uhhuh and and all
Loki does is just rewind it so we get
more information and more questions um
he who remains says you are quite a
Marvel I will be proud to lead with you
thank you for being on the
team what what is he talking about what
is Ron and K's history that that we
assume it is right now that was so crazy
that was maybe the craziest moment of
the episode the like what's craziest to
me Jess is the fact that it was paused
in the middle so he rewound it to like
five or 10 seconds earlier and then we
realized the word it was paused on was
the name Rona Ren Slayer so someone was
listening to it heard that name paused
it and said all right I got to get out
of here so I think it was Ren Slayer who
was listening to it I think was I think
in this past era of the TVA she heard
her name on that recording freaked out
and then left because like who else
would it I mean maybe Miss I feel like
Miss Mes would already know the history
of Rin Slayer um that's what's being
kept from Ren Slayers the fact that she
and Kang were supposed to be equal
Partners in their running of the TVA
right this is this is recorded going
back to when you said it has to be Ron
because she was listening to it this was
recorded where are they now in the past
that was is Loki in the past listening
to the recording he that's when he's
listening to it but I don't know when it
was recording when it was recorded
that's true okay because I looked at it
closely it looks like there is a date on
that in the orange text next to the
screen it looks like June 12th
2321 and so that I don't know if it's
just like something the designers put in
there and I don't know if that's when it
was last played or if it when or if it
was recorded on that date and also do
any of these dates matter if they're
removed from time exactly exactly that
that's the part of the the I love it and
hate it about the show right now is that
it doesn't matter if you even gave me a
date uh time does not matter right now
we are at the TVA that's outside of
space and time and it fluctuates so much
with time slipping that it does not
matter um but but I I like the idea that
it is ravona listening to it she heard
her name and paused it and then left and
then we're only listening from that
start I assumed it was mis minutes I
completely assumed it was mis minutes
but my assumption of assuming it was mis
minutes was because I was like someone
had to have been recording the
conversation right and if if Miss m is
just taking in everything that Kang uh
or he who remains has done then it would
make more reason for like why she would
have this recording because I don't
think ravona is just like who recorded
it like I'm I'm so confused right Miss
minutes must have recorded it and she's
she must have used it in that past
moment to
manipulate to manipulate Ren Slayer by
finally revealing the truth to her yeah
I think so in terms of what their
history must have been it sounded like
he called her quite a Marvel um going to
be proud to lead with you thank you for
being on my team which is like okay so
there was some kind of Civil War maybe
among the kangs and then RN Slayer might
have tipped the scales in favor of he
who remains and helped him win like so
does that mean that RN Slayer had the
secret to alith and gave him that weapon
because it sounded like he needed elath
control of elath to win that multiversal
War I think you're right and also that
would give reason to why in the trailer
we see that bit of what I we all assume
is in the trailer we see ravona there's
Hills behind her where I'm just assuming
it's where you get when you're pruned I
was like oh she got zipped back there
and it would oh my God that revealed
that elath doesn't attack her Elias
doesn't go after her cuz she's raona
she's the one that captured him maybe
he's afraid well I would love that
reveal more than anything I did assume
that it was the multiversal war and she
and maybe he just got he clearly left it
out in the finale that he got help from
other people during the mle versal war
but if he already created the Minutemen
Soldiers by then and the Minutemen
soldiers were able to help defeat the
other Kang variant so he already
enlisted other people by then and that's
why he was like you're the leader of the
TVA Minutemen soldiers thank you for
leading with me but I also calling
someone a Marvel like that they're
clearly in love I think they're an item
oh for sure they're already an item by
then yeah um you know the uh uh uh when
he we got to rewatch episode six of last
season because the way Jonathan major
says I pruned the other C or I pruned my
variant I tamed elath and like it kind
of sounds like now retroactively he's
compensating for something no he is he
didn't do it alone he didn't do it it
was raona that's why I said it was raona
Miss minutes like raon is Miss
minutes what did Obama say Obama was
right this whole time Obama was right I
knew it I knew it and they they snuck it
in Michael Waldren said you know what
put it in the finale put it in the
finale the random sound bite that almost
caed Obama the reelection campaign and
put it in there put it in there they'll
get this Jesus Christ yeah only Eric Vos
rockar we find this oh my God but no it
has to be it literally like I need and
even if I'm wrong I need it to be raona
like in Mis minutes like raona being
Miss minutes I need Miss minutes to be
raona and rabona was like I did it all
these kangs are stealing from me or like
I wanted to so bad and I I I love the
idea of going back to the finale and
looking at it how because he is he gets
up on that table he was like I was the
one that pulled you guys out of space
and time created this world so I could
like make sure you guys are all living
everyone's fine and safe and it's like
like M doesn't look like it no looks
like you got help from someone else and
you are owning it it'd be hard to do all
that alone I think you need yeah yeah
watching all the time yeah dictating
time um let's talk about uh OB the TVA
guide book um I want to know from you
like when did Obie write this TVA
handbook like how long has he been
around well he already he said 400 years
he said it was 400 years years ago that
him and Mobius crossed paths so he had
to be there from the very beginning like
if that tape recording was like yeah
let's fight this multiversal war he had
to have been one of the people with
ravona right like yeah I have I I also
have I don't know why but I feel like
hear me out I don't think Obie's gonna
be a good guy yeah I don't think Obie's
gonna be a good guy when he as soon as
he was like yeah miss m would do this
and then I just ran to agnostics every
few hundred years I was like it was just
you and Miss minutes there was nobody
else in this room it was just you and
Miss minutes every so often every
hundred years she like is there
something you know and you're in charge
of all the technology all of it there
has to be something you know that you're
not telling us no I think I think kiwan
maybe it's just I I just think he's so
and wonderful I think it's impossible to
make him a villain it just doesn't work
for me I well what if it's like a
villain that he doesn't know yet he
doesn't know that he's a villain like
maybe he's like oh I think I think
anything he's going to discover that he
served the wrong boss at some point or
that he was following orders but like he
is just a like utilitarian functional
character and he's doing such a good job
of that and I just kind of like that he
is this kind of like custodian Legacy
guardian of of the TVA that uh
regardless of you know there's like
people who serve the government
regardless of who's in the White House
you know these like long time deep
Staters who just want you know God I
just went down the rabbit hole but you
know what I mean like these guys in
these old in the state department or in
the pagon or whatever you know like
they're there he's like he's always
there I like that he is like a mixture
of Milt from Office Space because he's
just down in the in the dungeon and no
one talks to him but he's also Mr Meeks
he can do anything and he's just happy
to help okay I just think I I like
allerted alluded looted looted lur I
don't know what the word is that I was
like I think it will be like working for
the wrong boss situation where I was
like this is really fun this back and
forth of talking in the past and the
present but I do think someone's going
to weaponize it at one point and it's
not going to be good uh they're going to
be like oh here's the key to blow up the
moon and then it'll be like oh I
have the key to blow up the moon in the
future uh but he had to have been
working I think he had to be one of the
first people taken into the TVA he
clearly had to be he had to be cuz he's
in charge of all of it it's not like he
just showed up one day and was like I
know every bit of technology in the TVA
I think he was like I also help create
it yeah I I I do he's definitely an OG I
um I do have a a theory video in the
works uh it's coming out on the new
officers channel on Monday that's just
about like why no one remembers OB CU
that's like a very important detail the
fact that he kind of remembers the rest
of everything but everyone else's
memories have been wiped so like why was
he question that's a good question
let's do before we wrap let's kind of do
a bit of a heat check because uh full
disclosure to our viewers I mentioned
this on inside Marvel I've seen the
first two episodes I know what's coming
in episode two uh the questions we're
talking about here are big long season
questions so like don't worry you
haven't been spoiled for anything for
the season or for next episode but I I
want to caution everyone right now I'm
riding High season 2 episode one was one
of the best things Marvel has ever made
season 2 episode
2 you
you said it you said it you said that I
don't I did I don't I don't know I don't
know I kind of disagree more with
disagree good but I understood I
understand where maybe a little
situation is with it but I was like it
didn't deter me it didn't deter me
enough good and I hope I hope how you
felt about it is how everyone feels
about it I hope I'm wrong I hope I am WR
it the thing is it doesn't like um I
I'll be honest me and secret Invasion
wasn't the best uh best of friends and
there were like I would let one episode
go if the next episode was better and it
did not do that for me right and I think
the second epod this first episode was
so good that I was like the first the
second episode for me is like 70% and I
was like that's still higher than 50
yeah I'm just amazed that you know at
that uh press screening they showed us
two episodes why not just leave it at
one like why show two that's why I think
some of the critics review news on like
IGN and other places were so mixed it's
cuz you showed everyone that bad second
episode but it's not bad it's not bad it
has a lot of good stuff in it it just
has some bad like really rough pacing I
would say so I'm just saying that now to
caution everyone I want everyone to go
in with low expectations so that way if
you end up liking the episode you can
just come yell at me and be like what
are you talking about I'd rather you
have that impression rather than go in
with like high Skyhigh expectations and
be disappointed yeah I thought the
second episode was slow but that might
be me yeah you guys you guys go watch it
uh we'll see we're going to leave it
there for this episode of the sneak peek
we'll be back next week but we got a big
week coming up on new rock stars in the
breakroom in the Deep dive so we got why
no one remembers or Boris we got a film
ranks episode so a new series we're
doing on the new rockstars network is
called film ranks you're going to
freaking love it it's like a a a two
hander you know a one two punch we got
the the listicle that comes out on the
on the new Rockstar Channel but then we
got a how we made it
deliberation piece of content that's
equally fun that comes out in the break
room um inside Marvel our reaction
episode 2 from me and mod Garrett coming
out on the break room on Thursday
evening our uh my my Easter egg
breakdown of Loki episode 2 coming out
on the main channel on Thursday night we
got a breakdown of gen V Episode 5
coming out on Friday uh and uh you
should be able to watch my deep dive of
James gamon's aliens on oh
what I just I just went to I I told Ash
I just went to a James Cameron the the
abys the abyss special edition
Q&A I I Jessica said it here James
Cameron is weirdly really funny he he
was throwing in like standup bits and I
was not prepared for it it was the
weirdest Q&A the abyss I would I alien
needs a deep dive I'm so excited for you
that's going to be that's going to be so
fun oh my God it's it's yes I'm very
proud of the video uh and I got to say
James Cameron regardless of what people
say about his dialogue or whatever it is
I don't think the guy has made a bad
movie I think he the best bading average
of any director what are people saying
bad about his his well a lot of people
don't really connect to the abyss or I
think some people look at the dialogue
and like T2 or true lies or Avatar or
way of water and just be like oh the the
dialogue's pretty service level like
nope nope then you don't understand what
the purpose of dialogue in movies is the
purpose of dialogue is to just like you
know reveal char move the plot forward
uh set up structure in Exposition and
like that's all it needs to be yeah I
have the most beef with James Cameron
out of every director in the human in
the r like I have the most beef with
this human being as a human being but
those movies those damn movies some of
the stuff he said after that that
submarine imploded was a little rough he
immediately tweeted about it I said
didn't to say anything I said James J
why are you going on CNN talking about
it no needs to hear from you right now
dude asked for that James so James you
idiot he was so okay continue I'm sorry
I'll go off about leave it be sure to
follow Jess at Lulu Clemens you can
follow me at eaos follow new rockstars
on all social platforms and we'll see
you next week for our sneak peek at
episode three bye
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]